en prison c'était très difficile pour
vous non vous avez retrouvé les les
railleries les insultes de l'école pire
que ça parce que en prison il y a une
hiérarchie sociale
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue dans tout le
monde en a parlé merci alors Patrick
vous êtes né le 30 juin 1970 à
Montigny-lès-Metz en Moselle ou votre
famille habite rue vénézilos tout près
du long talus qui bordent la voie ferrée
de L'Express Paris Metz
ouvrier spécialisé
d'abord à la Solac c'est une société qui
fabrique et qui usine la ferraille en
fait et ensuite chez Citroën
votre maman était stimodactylo jusqu'à
votre naissance ensuite elle s'est
occupée de vous et oui
alors à l'école votre grande taille
votre grand nez votre allure dégingandé
et vos cheveux roux suscite des
moqueries même des insultes tout à fait
et ne pas avoir ma timidité le fait
d'être introverti pas la capacité de
pouvoir répondre et effectivement j'en
ai beaucoup souffert alors vous vous
renfermez sur vous-même et vous vous
réfugiez dans votre collection de
timbres en fait votre rêve c'est de
devenir cuisinier d'ailleurs à 14 ans
vous arrêtez l'école pour commencer une
formation de CAP de cuisine
alors à l'époque des faits vous avez 16
ans vous êtes encore un peu un enfant on
peut dire vous n'êtes pas vous n'êtes
pas demeurer vous n'êtes pas débile mais
vous êtes vraiment en retard quoi tout à
fait n'ayant pas peur des mots
effectivement un enfant un enfant
alors le 28 septembre 1986 vers 18h45
vous rentrez avec votre papa votre maman
et votre frère de week-end dans la Meuse
où vous possédez une maison de campagne
pendant que vos parents et votre frère
déchargent la voiture vous vous dirigez
vers la poubelle administrative de
l'usine de Mathieu et bar où vous venez
chercher des timbres pour votre
collection
effectivement j'avais pour habitude de
me rendre à cette petite poubelle où il
y avait que des déchets administratifs
pour essayer d'assouvir ma passion pour
la philatélie et de récolter quelques
timbres vous en trouviez
de temps en temps pas à chaque cours et
ce fameux soir j'étais revenu Bruille
le soir même à 19h30 les corps de deux
enfants sont retrouvés couchés sur les
rails du talus à quelques centaines de
mètres de chez vous
il s'agit de Cyril Benning et Alexandre
Beckrich 8 ans tous les deux qui aimait
venir faire du vélo rue vénézilla vous
les connaissez reconnaissez un des deux
le petit Alexandre puisqu'il habitait à
quelques maisons de celle de mes parents
par contre son petit copain je ne
connaissais pas peut-être croiser comme
ça de vie dans le quartier mais sans
vraiment sans plus alors il est joué sur
les voies des affectées ou stationner
les wagons de marchandises oui
apparemment j'ai super la suite que
c'était un air de jeu pour privilégier
pour les enfants alors quand on trouve
les corps des deux garçonnés la scène
est insoutenable ils ont le crâne
explosé à coup de Pierre des fragments
osseux des morceaux de matière
cervicales ont été projetés dans un
rayon de 2 mètres lorsque l'enquête de
voisinage commence les policiers notent
rien à signaler chez les deals tout à
fait mais le lendemain il y a un coup de
fil anonyme
et vous êtes né en garde à vue interrogé
sur mon emploi du temps et puis
je vais finir par dire que je me jetais
dans leur organisée los et ma raison
dans cette rue pour chercher les timbres
alors vous êtes interrogé mais sans
résultat parce qu'en fait les enfants
étaient tués entre 17 et 18h et vous
vous êtes revenus avec vos parents de
votre maison de campagne dans la Meuse
autour de 18h45 le meurtre disons a eu
lieu au moins trois quarts d'heure avant
le retour de la famille dieles mais
quelques mois plus tard un nouveau
témoignage va tout changer
un nouveau témoignage qui tombe et qui
dit avoir entendu des pleurs d'enfants
aux alentours de 18h45 alors
effectivement pour la police ça change
la donne et là effectivement à ce
moment-là j'étais dans la rue donc à ce
moment là vous pouvez être le meurtrier
pour être le maître
alors après 30 heures d'interrogatoire
vous finissez par avouer pourquoi
pourquoi elle a lassitude je sais pas si
vous avez vous arrivez là maintenant
tout de suite à imaginer ce que ça peut
représenter 30 heures c'est pas 30 ans
dans votre salon c'est pas 30 heures en
très bonne compagnie c'est la police
judiciaire qui sont là pour accueillir
des aveux pour pouvoir obtenir du
résultat et encore une fois 16 ans je
n'étais qu'un enfant donc oui
effectivement j'ai endossé l'habit du
parfait coupable mais je pense qu'il
serait quand même bon de dire qu'avant
moi deux majeurs ont été amenés avouer
le meurtre dans les détails comme moi
j'ai été amené à le faire donc si des
majeurs peuvent le faire un enfant mais
c'est malléable ça n'en fait pas ta
modeler
30 heures s'endormir 31 s'endormir sans
manger et c'est
un souvenable c'est insotable je pense
qu'il y a pas de mots pour expliquer les
conditions quand on je m'entend dire
même encore aujourd'hui si on vient en
parler oui mais il y a eu des temps de
repos
si je prends un temps de repos c'est une
mise en condition pour obtenir du
résultat parce qu'on vous pose un tas de
questions et à la sortie du repos on
veut les réponses donc c'est pas un
temps de repos n'hésitez pas
trois ou quatre il se relayé en fait
donc à ce moment-là vous pensez que les
policiers vont se rendre compte que vous
avez menti en fait vous rentrerez chez
vous 15 ans plus tard 15 ans plus tard
vous êtes venir le plus jeune condamné à
perpétuité de France c'est à dire que le
fait que vous soyez mineur n'a pas joué
pour vous absolument pas c'est rare ici
ça quand même c'est unique c'est tout
simplement lamentable parce que j'estime
qu'il y a pas de mots quoi c'est c'est
on a détruit mon adolescence on a
détruit une partie de moi et une partie
de ma famille vous ne serez innocenté
qu'en 2002 en fait tout ça parce que
vous ne vouliez pas avouer aux policiers
que vous alliez chercher des timbres
c'est vrai dans la poubelle ça part de
ce petit mensonge qui j'estime n'est
même pas un mensonge c'est une mission
de dire la vérité pourquoi parce que en
sachant tout ce que j'avais vécu par
rapport à l'école les moqueries les
railleries même si aujourd'hui je me
rends compte que c'est stupide ça n'a
même pas lieu d'être mais l'enfant il
n'aurait pas supporté en plus qu'on dise
mais t'as vu c'est le petit deal cela
c'est un fouille poubelle ça aurait été
la goutte d'eau quand c'est déborder une
base tout ça par peur du condira-t-on
alors le crime n'a jamais été élucidé à
un moment on a mis ça sur le dos de
Francis Heaulme mais le test ADN ont
prouvé que c'était pas possible que ça
soit lui le dossier est toujours ouvert
et j'espère très sincèrement avant tout
pour les familles des victimes pour ma
propre famille et puis moi-même et mon
entourage qu'un jour on sera ce qui
s'est passé sur ce talus et pourquoi on
a enlevé la vie à ces deux enfants qui
comme moi ne demande qu'une seule chose
vivre grandir et être heureux
en prison c'était très difficile pour
vous non vous avez retrouvé les les
railleries les insultes de l'école pire
que ça parce que en prison il y a une
hiérarchie sociale malheureusement il y
a les délits qui font être respectés
comme le braquage et autres et puis
après on va descendre descendre
descendre jusqu'au moment où on va
arriver au meurtre de personnes âgées
mais après les personnes âgées il y a
encore pire c'est le meurtre un enfant
c'est vraiment c'est des gens qu'on ne
peut pas respecter ce sont des gens qui
sont là pour subir pour souffrir et qui
ne doivent pas exister je suis
malheureusement passé par toutes les
étapes ça va commencer par des insultes
des regards
les violences physiques leur raquettes
et puis bien évidemment
le viol
vous dites on m'a volé 15 ans de ma vie
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne rattrape
pas alors il faut essayer de vivre avec
l'État inversé un million d'euros
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait de Semion
d'euros
700000 euros ont été destinés 40 000
euros ont été destinés à mon frère Alain
et 80 000 euros pour chacun de mes
parents ce qui fait un total de 900000 €
et les 100000 euros restants destiné à
mon avis avocat
mais ce que vous avez vécu ça ce chiffre
pas j'imagine vous savez on peut on peut
chiffrer
quinze ans de galère par rapport à un
manque à gagner au niveau d'un salaire
mais est-ce que vous pensez sincèrement
qu'on peut chiffrer un préjudice moral
un préjudice physique ça se chiffre pas
et si on avait eu la décence de me
demander ce que j'aurais souhaité en
réparation croyez-moi sur parole
j'aurais jamais demandé un centime à
l'état mais ce que j'aurais tout
simplement souhaité que les gens qui ont
eu affaire à moi de près ou de loin
vivent et subissent ce que j'ai vécu est
subi durant ces 15 années et là on
aurait été quitte
vous en voulez à qui aujourd'hui j'en
veux à personne aujourd'hui j'ai pas de
temps à perdre j'ai plus de temps à
perdre et la vengeance la haine elle
sert à rien si elle permettait de faire
revenir la jeunesse à mes parents ça
pouvait ramener la vie à ses enfants oui
j'en aurai mais la haine ne sert à rien
et j'essaie tout simplement d'avancer
sereinement dans la vie alors
aujourd'hui vous êtes magazinier cariste
dans une fabrique d'articles culinaires
vous avez trouvé l'amour effectivement
jeune fiancée de 18 ans qui est qui est
charmante
effectivement comme n'importe qui j'ai
pu avoir différentes petites histoires
puisque je suis loin d'être un don Juan
je suis juste Patrick mais je pense que
c'est la seule qui a su me comprendre
qu'assumer qu'assumer Patrick et non pas
de dels même si on peut pas dissocier
dix de Patrick puisque là fait partie de
l'autre mais qui même pour ce que je
suis et non pas pour ce que je
représente
quand vous êtes tous les deux vous
parlez des fois de l'affaire bien sûr ça
fait partie de ma vie ça fait partie de
notre vie aujourd'hui mais ça prend
jamais le dessus on a notre vie à
construire on a nos projets ensemble et
on avance sereinement vous dites je suis
l'homme le plus heureux de la terre
aujourd'hui effectivement je suis
parce que je suis plus tout seul je suis
j'ai une compagne j'ai une fiancée parce
que c'est le vrai mot qui m'aime
vraiment qui est prête à faire n'importe
quoi pour moi comme moi personnellement
je suis prêt à faire n'importe quoi pour
elle alors si c'était à refaire Patrick
qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil
c'est très délicat à vous répondre je
sais pas je pense que je resterai le
Patrick que vous avez devant vous
aujourd'hui
le jour vous allez mourir voudrait qu'on
marque quoi sur votre tombe vous savez
quelle question mais j'ai pas envie de
mourir j'ai pas envie de mourir parce
que je pense que après tout ce qui m'est
arrivé j'ai beaucoup de choses à faire
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
je n'ai pas de haine et j'ai envie de
tendre une main vers les autres ceux qui
en ont besoin on pourrait marquer
Patrick Dils il est mort sans haine
pourquoi pas
on voit Patrick j'étais très heureux de
rallumer la lumière sur vous merci à
vous et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu